despite popular belief there are
actually a handful of characters that
David and Dan managed to do justice in
the later Seasons which is where I'm
going to be focusing primarily because
this list would be full of amazing
characters who died in the earlier
Seasons like Tywin and Joffrey that
David and Dan physically couldn't ruin
so the requirement is that they have to
be alive in at least season 7 or 8 also
I feel like it would kind of be cheating
if I picked minor Side characters like
pod the rod because they have very
little screen time and developments
without further do number 10 Sansa Stark
now I know this may be initially
controversial but keep in mind it's
really hard to find 10 good characters
that weren't ruined so the first half of
this list still has characters that are
partially ruined Sansa out of all the
main characters to me has the best
executed Arc that doesn't have a bunch
of major flaws there are definitely
aspects about it that are still flawed
like there not being a lot of defining
moments in her Arc that show her
progress and then multiple minor issues
that start to add up examples of those
include her General stupidity in certain
areas like not telling John about the
veil and overly trusting Littlefinger in
season 7 then the general contrived
surrounding her character like
unjustifiably hating daena so much also
it would definitely be nice if we saw
more development of Sansa overcoming the
conflicts of running a massive Kingdom
and the north as a whole there's easily
a lot of conflict that you can Brew up
in this setting especially given the
circumstances of the story throughout
the later Seasons we are just told how
great of a leader Sansa is but David and
Dan never really show us that they focus
a lot of the show's time in other areas
and probably think the complexities of
running a kingdom is boring when it
isn't like look at the earlier seasons
of the show or even House of the Dragon
Sansa essentially Falls victim to the
rushing of the story however from a
story perspective there's nothing that
obliterates her character it's all
partially logical she has a believable
character Arc and she has arguably the
best ending out of the main characters
on top of her consistently being
relevant within the story unlike some
other characters so overall you kind of
have to squin your eyes when viewing
Sansa because her general form is intact
but the second you focus your eyes and
look at the details it mostly falls
apart number nine Samuel tarle Samuel as
a character isn't entirely unscathed and
still has some shaky aspects about
himself but in an overall sense Samuel
tle from a personality perspective is
relatively fine and not overly destroyed
the couple bad aspects about him that
I'm referring to is samel becoming Sam
the Slayer and him easily becoming The
Grandmaster of Kings Landing without
proper training the first one is
obviously pretty rough however I'm
willing to slightly look past this since
everyone became Immortal Gods with plot
armor during that episode then for the
second one him becoming Grandmaster is
kind of a fan service ending that
doesn't make sense due to his relative
inexperience but it at least is the
correct direction ction for the
character Samuel also doesn't have a lot
to do in the final season and basically
is just there to tell Jon he's a
Targaryen but his season six and seven
goal was pretty important in that he
learns about the deposit of dragon glass
and dragon Stone along with him being a
POV character his relationship with
Gilly and his son is largely overlooked
and Sam is essentially the Middle Road
character where David and Dan didn't do
anything great with him nor did they
decimate him like Tyrion number eight
torment now tor in comparison to saml is
kind of the opposite I think his
character in terms of how he's
implemented into the story doesn't do
anything overly stupid that does a
disservice to him however I think David
and Dan have severely dumbed down his
character since the earlier Seasons he
more or less has become just a comedic
relief character when he used to also be
a more intimidating bold and serious
wildling who has sporadic burst of
Comedy to release any builtup tension it
makes sense for his character to become
more friendly over the season reasons
but I think David and Dan do it so much
to the point that he loses an integral
aspect about himself like the whole
Brien bait romance was funny at first
and essentially becomes a weird fan
service es meme that keeps returning
that simultaneously robs the character
of any seriousness along with them doing
overly silly things like the character
chugging giant smoke for a century he's
still a very fun and enjoyable figure to
watch but he does lose that layer of
depth from the earlier Seasons that
balanced him out that's why I'm putting
him at number nine since he has this one
negative aspect but he's still largely
intact to the point that he's not overly
ruined number seven Davos cworth this is
a character that I see a lot of love for
and to me I never really loved him that
much in his earlier Seasons he's
obviously great like in his wonderful
pairing with Shireen and his morally
complex pairing with Stannis Baratheon
however after season five he
spontaneously joins John's side and
becomes his yes man like torans I think
he loses a lot of of his complexity and
David and Dan don't do a lot with his
character to make him overly interesting
he's my definition of the most neutral
character in the later Seasons an
example of an easy hanging fruit to
develop Davos is the death of matthos
and whether or not he's still mataran
for that instead that goes unexplored
and you probably can't think of anything
personal about the character that gets
developed in the later Seasons he's kind
of just a for the ride and fundamentally
supports John like that's fine and on a
technicality he isn't ruined but he also
isn't doing anything impressive within
the story number six Grey Worm similar
to Davos greyworm is a very simple
character that you really can't mess up
that badly although David and Dan still
mess up one aspect about him towards the
end in which he flat out doesn't kill
Jon which essentially acts as a plot
contrivance but besides that he has a
good Revenge Arc his romance with mande
was really gratifying since its two
characters so entrenched in misery for
their entire lives and they finally find
love that reinv Ates them to then have
that all ripped away by an evil queen
makes grey worm's pure rage deeply
connecting greyworm because of this
ironically has a better mad Queen Arc
than Daenerys because it's much more
Justified and you understand his
perspective more albeit it's obviously
more simple I just wish they pushed that
anger fied side of him more and had him
show down against Jon at the end because
that's really the more realistic path to
take his character given that he was
executing prisoners for breathing not
him allowing these traitors to do
whatever they want in the end and all of
his anger evaporating however I think
grey worm's ending of honoring mande is
still pretty wholesome and works well
too just don't tell them that there's
apparently poisonous butterflies on na
that will decimate them number five
olena Tyrell I would put Alena a bit
higher but I feel like that would kind
of be cheating since she really isn't in
the later Seasons all that much David
and Dan really nailed her two scenes
within season 7 in which she gives some
great advice to Dany and has one of the
best death scenes in the show show like
it's genuinely pretty jarring how good
her overall death scene was in
comparison to so many the other mediocre
to terrible scenes within the season one
aspect that really carries it is that
it's a long awaited payoff and that
Elena finally gets to tell Jamie that
she killed Joffrey it leads to the
juiciest of reactions and Diana rig
absolutely Nails the scene and utterly
relishes in the pain and misery of Jamie
Lannister that smug little smile she
gives Jamie such an iconic moment that
it easily cements itself as one of the
best scenes in the later Seasons then
besides this her talk with Daenerys
feels the most genuine because she's
actually giving her good advice unlike
Tyrion olena encouraging Dany to become
a Targaryen and not be afraid to show
her true power was what should have
happened all along and it's too bad she
didn't listen to her Alena may only have
a couple of scenes within season 7 but
they were impactful enough to land her
onto my list because of how perfectly
executed they were and how great of a
character she was number four Theon
Greyjoy from an overall character Arc
perspective Theon is pretty Flawless he
has the most consistent and tangible Arc
in the show to the point that it would
be almost impossible to mess up and
David and Dan don't they still rough it
up a bit towards the beginning of season
8 but it wasn't terrible David and Dan
have this Grand setup for theon's
Redemption and saving Yara by finally
becoming a confident and fearless leader
he overcomes the nightmare of reek and
finally takes back his true identity of
being a grey Joy however it seems that
David and Dan didn't really carry over
this effort into season 8 because Theon
simply waltzes into euron's Fleet at
night kills a couple of guards and
rescues Yara with almost no conflict
it's a little bit of a bummer that there
wasn't a grand rescue kind of heist that
has more impactful payoff or even
overcoming euron someone that Theon
previously ran away from honestly
thinking about it now it would make much
more sense for Theon to kill euron than
Jamie luckily though this was the only
misstep his reunion with Sansa is really
sweet and heartfelt and the irony in
that he dies protecting bran a character
he was thought of for killing is
actually some brilliant writing he may
not have a lot of screen time in really
dialog scenes even but these points in
his character Arc are pretty much
perfect number three Jorah Mormont sir
Jorah just barely included enough in the
story to not feel left out and even
though I'd like some more dialogue
scenes for him you could essentially say
that for most of the side characters in
The later Seasons the main reason why
I'm putting him at number three is that
his ending was by far the best thing to
have happened during the long night he
may have kind of teleported outside of
Winterfell to save Daenerys in that
moment but hey I'll give it a pass since
it makes sense from a character
standpoint and not necessarily A
contextual logistic standpoint but at
least in comparison to say Theon there
isn't a major aspect about his journey
that was very underwhelming his reunion
scenes were charged with so much heart
and emotion his character pairings were
all very intriguing so much to the point
that you just want more of them and he
was even regularly included in the
action Serj is essentially my gosu from
one of the most consistently good side
characters aided with the fact that his
overall story arc isn't that complex so
David and Dan couldn't ruin it that
badly number two Brien of Tarth I think
she's one of two characters that
genuinely have some great character
development in season 8 because that's
the main thing about Theon and Jorah and
that their character journey is
essentially just come to an end without
them changing a lot which obviously
isn't a bad thing meanwhile Brienne goes
through an entire end goal payoff for
her character in which she finally
becomes a knight she finds love and
achieves an ultimate goal on top of
there still being some good buildup to
Jamie and brien's romance in which Jamie
dismantles the mean figure she viewed
him as just the nighting scene alone
would easily put Brien within my top
three and is probably the best scene in
season 8 the genuine and Serene
happiness that gushes from both of these
characters is massively cathartic and
it's one of those rare victories within
Game of Thrones it's also written really
well in having the scene slowly progress
and build the excitement as the ceremony
goes on along with rine jawadi elevating
the wonderful emotions with his
outstanding music then you can't help
but feel so much joy for the character
as she finally finds love in her life
that's something that she always
struggled with and was emotionally beat
down by so having this love scene was
great for the character even though
jimie leaves right away the love doesn't
disappear and even she partially redeems
Jaime's ending with yet another great
scene in which she fills out the white
book with all of J's good Deeds through
and through a really well done job and
the main reason why she isn't in my
number one spot is that she didn't have
anything to do in season 7 number one
sandor clean I feel like the primary
reason why David and Dan were able to
not ruin sandor as a character is
because he fundamentally plays into
their writing strengths and those
strengths are generally more vulgar
based comedy given that it seems David
and Dan fall back on that kind of
dialogue a lot in the later Seasons
although sander was really the only
character that wasn't hurt by this if
anything it even helped him since he had
a lot of iconic funny moments sandor
uses humor as both a way to destroy
people and even as a defense mechanism
the only person that can get past this
defense is Arya given that she spent so
much time with him like seeing them
together in witnessing a more mellowed
out Hound was genuinely outstanding and
I'm really sad we didn't get more of
that like that was one of my favorite
aspects from seasons 3 and four their
Duo is infectious and having his Arc
coincide with Aras in that he shows her
how Revenge consumed himself and
convinces her to escape was honestly
pretty good it's a perfect Arc for the
character and even pairs well with an
additional main character then his
ending was also great and even though it
was a bit fanservicey I can easily
forgive it given that there were far
greater issues about the episode having
both the hound and the mountain die to
fire was surprisingly poetic both from a
character perspective and his relevance
within the story The Hound was
consistently amazing and prevalent
throughout I know him coming back into
the story in season 6 is kind of a Hot
Topic but between all of the absurdly
dumb things that happened later on it's
not a major deal that in the direction
it puts the character in was actually
interesting thank God David and Dan did
a great job with sandor clean because he
has always been one of my favorites
unlike what they did with Tyrion thank
you for watching and this video was a
part of a double feature so check out
the top 10 characters ruined by David
and Dan also let me know in the comments
what your ranking would be for this
video